hello defcon i speak to you today for my
own version of the bat cave
the ultimate in social distancing this
is hacking the hybrid cloud and i am
shaw metcalf
i'm the founder of trimark a
professional services company that helps
organizations better secure their
microsoft
platform including the microsoft cloud
and vmware infrastructure
i'm a microsoft certified master in
active directory and a microsoft mvp
i've spoken at a number of conferences
and i'm excited to be back speaking at
defcon
even if i'm not physically at defcon
last year i keynoted the defcon cloud
village and three years ago gave a talk
on hacking the cloud at defcon
this talk will take a journey through
the hybrid cloud starting with the
comparison between cloud and
virtualization
discussing how on-prem active directory
domain controllers can be compromised
i will also walk through the cloud
hosted managing managed active directory
deployments from aws azure and gcp
since this is hybrid talk i will walk
through some hybrid components and see
how they can be attacked
i'll touch on cloud administration and
identity access management or im
concepts
and finally walk through escalation
scenarios for compromising cloud hosted
on-prem domain controllers aws and azure
first we need to talk about what hybrid
cloud is at least in the context of this
talk
there are likely lots of definitions of
hybrid cloud do this i'm defining hybrid
cloud as something on-prem and something
in the cloud
this typically means infrastructure
on-prem and in the cloud
more is than strict sas now that we've
defined hybrid cloud let's look at three
common scenarios
the first is the on prime active
directory environment with office 365
sas services
sas stands for software as a service
many organizations are leveraging the
cloud for infrastructure as a service or
is
as their cloud data center the third
scenario here is an on prime active
directory with a cloud managed ad
as an additional or resource forest
since cloud can be used in many ways
it's likely that most organizations use
a combination of these
among others this section covers
virtualization top
concepts and controls as foundational
information to better set up and
describe potential attacks
conceptually the cloud is virtualization
certainly from an is perspective
amazon has used zen and a switch to
nitro
azure uses a custom version of hyper-v
core and
google cloud platform uses kvm
now there is a cloud fabric that ties
the virtualization elements together
with orchestration which is what makes
the cloud the cloud
so this diagram shows azure is with a vm
and related components this is similar
to on-prem virtualization
and amazon's nitro is pretty cool the
nitro hypervisor can take advantage of
nitro
optimized hardware including a nitro
security chip
any instance created prior to nitro is
still running zen
also has this concept of connectivity
between the aws managed active directory
that they host themselves
and ec2 which is their ias
environment within the aws cloud and
then of course since they
you can host windows servers and windows
systems and other types of systems you
can also integrate and connect to
other cloud environments this
demonstrates how cloud can get complex
pretty fast
and you can run vmware on-prem and in
aws
and azure and gcp
domain controllers control the keys to
the kingdom and require special security
protections that are often ignored on
virtual platforms
compromising physical domain controllers
boils down to either gaining physical
access or compromising an out-of-band
management system like ilo
ilo hosts a web server on port 2381 and
we can scan for this using powershell
so if ilo is hosted on the same network
as production systems and clients
such as workstations we can scan and
identify ilo
ilo has had a number of security issues
with firmware patches available but
the issue is that pretty much no one
updates firmware on physical servers
airbus security has identified many of
these security issues with ilo
from accessing memory to an rce to get
read write memory access to the ability
to
execute arbitrary commands via dma to
gain
host access through ilo even when ilo is
disabled
and i have a link at the bottom that
includes a list even beyond
what i have up here and a go scanner to
discover vulnerable servers running ilo
when vmware is hosting virtual dc's
which is probably around 95 percent of
the organizations are better certainly
the larger ones
there's different ways that you could
compromise vmware to get access to a
virtual domain controller
this could involve compromising an
account with rights to vmware often this
is a regular user account that is a
member of an 80 group called
vmware admins or we just need to
compromise an account that has vmware
access
to or at least two
at least one virtual domain controller
potentially more
if we can compromise the system which
runs vcenter we can ultimately
compromise vmware
also every esxi server has a root
account and most of the time every esxi
server has the same root password
which may be the organization default
password which could be guessed or found
in a password file
we can compromise the vcenter system we
can compromise the vsphere environment
and the vmware vix api has functionality
that allows for direct access to
guest os's which is used by solutions
such as vmware
site recovery manager this requires
vmware tools to be installed on the
guest os or vm
the vix api allows guest operations such
as starting stopping the application
file directory manipulation uploading
downloading files
all within the guest os without
requiring any network connectivity to
the virtual machine
this functionality may also be used by
via vsphere accounts with limited
privileges
to access a guest os without the need to
authenticate
there is a scenario where an account
with vcenter privileges can use the
vsphere api to interact with a local os
installation
of vmware tools to allow a pass-through
session for an unprivileged account to
connect to that virtual
machine and execute local commands since
this applies to
virtual domain controllers active
directory could be compromised in this
manner by allowing
execution of commands locally on the
virtual dc
with accounts not normally allowed local
logon access to the dc's
for hyper-v the attacks are similar to
vmware we compromise an account with
rights or find a way to compromise the
server
either through a server admin account
discover the local admin password
or a modified group policy to gain
access to the server
so i decided i would take a look at the
so-called big three cloud hosting
providers manage active directory
environments and then focus on what this
means to pen testers and red teamers
the manage active directory environment
does not provide 80 admin rights to the
ad environment so the customer will
never have domain admin rights or even
domain controller access
the cloud provider controls 80
infrastructure management and delegates
rights to
ous and 80 components to the customer
let's start with amazon aws directory
services for microsoft active directory
that's quite the mouthful
the aws managed ad has an aws delegated
group so you that contains the
delegation groups
which the customers provided membership
in and access to
the aws reserved ou is controlled
exclusively by the aws system
there is a customer ou created in the
managed id domain that is typically
named after the 80 subdomain
or the first part of the fully qualified
domain name
or the domains netbios name this
customer ou contains
ous for computers and users
aws managed ads spins up two domain
controllers which are in
different network segments but in the
same act directory site
the default domain admin account retains
the default name
administrator though this is moved to
the aws reserve w
when a customer creates an aws managed
id their first account in the ad
environment is called admin
and is granted full delegated rights to
the ad environment for that customer
not to the domain controllers or 80
admin rights to
the full ad the domain password is
default still seven characters but there
are five
aws created fine grain password policies
which are delegated to the customer to
modify
based on the group policy linked to the
domain controllers ou i was able to
identify a pretty decent audit policy
that was missing kerberos auditing which
means kerberosting activity would be
missed
the first customer account admin is
created with the description that notes
the customer ou distinguished name
so it's very nice that they provide this
description so that way you can quickly
and easily identify where this ou is
there are several delegation groups in
the aws managed ad environment
all these are named with prefix aws
delegated and are contained
in the aws delegated groups ou the aws
delegated administrators group is the
primary customer admin group
there are also delegation groups for
managed service accounts adding
workstations to the main kerberos
delegation dns and server administration
let's take a look at azure active
directory domain services
while azure active directory is not
exactly active directory since it's a
cloud directory with no kerberos or ntlm
authentication group policy or ldap
azure ad domain services is active
directory just like you would have on a
corporate network
in his microsoft's managed active
directory
so this environment azure adds has
several top level ou's that are created
these are prefixed with aadd
and the aadc computers
and aadc users ous are the primary
customer use
the azure adds domain controllers are in
the same network and at least
in this instance that i created had
sequential ips.4.5
the default domain admin account is
called dcaas
admin and remains in the default users
are you there is one fine grain password
policy that's pre-created
i'm not going to try to read the name as
it is it's a bit tough with all the aaa
and dds
but the customer has delegated modify
rights to this fine grain password
policy object
i can't see any auditing configuration
set in gpo so i have to assume that they
are set via local policy which i can't
see without domain controller access
azure ds has a few delegation groups
which are prefixed with aadc
and are in the aadc users ou
the primary customer group is aad
dc administrators which is delegated
full control to many ous and 80
components
i'm pretty sure when microsoft came up
with the names for these groups they
were not thinking about having to say
this out loud in a row
so thank you microsoft for that moving
on to the third and final managed ad
environment that i reviewed
recently this is the google cloud
platform managed active directory
it's interesting to note that the gcp
managed ad seems to cost about twice
what the amazon aws and
microsoft azure managed ad environments
cost because they're about a hundred
dollars each
the gcp managed ad environment has a
single root ou for the customer called
cloud
with a single child iu called computers
the cloud service objects ou
contains the delegation groups gcp
manage ad
is different in that from from the
others that i just talked about in that
domain controllers are running windows
server 2019
though the active directory force
functional level is still set to 2012 r2
also the active directory recycle bin
which enables rapid undelete capability
is not enabled which is interesting
the default domain administrator account
keeps the default name administrator
and it's disabled so gcp spins up
a second domain admin account called
cloud svc
admin and this account is enabled
the domain password policy is default
and the customer can create fine grain
password policies
and with this the dc event auditing is
not configured through group policy so
again i couldn't identify how it may be
configured
gcp managed ad has several delegation
groups they start with cloud service
and these are stored in the cloud
service objects ou the cloud service all
administrators in the cloud service
administrators of the primary customer
admin groups
gcp delegation groups include computer
admins managed service account
admins and others this slide captures
some of the common themes of the three
managed 80 environments i
reviewed i used a version of the trimark
active directory assessment tool that i
wrote to perform the review of the
different 80 environments which enabled
me to capture data for all three and
identify the
key security features and delegation in
about a day to put this talk together or
at least this part of it
the bottom of the slide i provide a link
to an active directory security review
powershell script that i wrote
and published in june the link points to
the article where i highlight
key 80 security items to check and what
to check for and the powershell script
simplifies the data collection
part so analysis is much simpler so it's
good to check that out it'd be helpful
if you're looking at an environment such
as these
so since the customer does not actually
have 80 admin rights to a managed ad
environment there's not much point in
attempting to
escalate to da better to identify which
managed ad environment it is and
enumerate the managed ad privilege
groups
to determine which accounts are highly
privileged uh
interesting note about azure active
directory domain services
microsoft's uh managed ad it can be
managed by azure id accounts and these
are synchronized into azure addds
or even by on-prem ad accounts that are
synced in from the on-prem
uh ad environment and these are synced
using the on-prem
azure id connect system through azure ad
to
azure ad domain services and if password
hash sync is enabled which it usually is
then the on prime80 account password
hash
is included normally password hash sync
does a hash of a hash
but when syncing through to azure ad
domain services
that original ad password hash is is
retained
and synchronized so that way it can the
password can actually be used in azure
act directory domain services
so there are several cloud components
that connect on-prem to cloud
this connectivity has some very
interesting implications
amazon's ad connector is effectively an
on-prem ad authentication proxy
ad connector is designed to provide an
easy way to establish a trusted
relationship between your
active directory and aws so when 80
connector is configured it
enables the ability to sign into aws
applications with on-prem ad credentials
join aws windows instances to the
on-prem
a.d domain and provides federated
sign-in to the aws management console
by mapping these on-prem identities to
aws
i am rolls and
80 connector can't be used with custom
applications since it's just for aws
basically a user opens the secure custom
sign-in page supplies their act director
username and password
this authentication request sent over
ssl to the ad connector
and then the ad connector performs ldap
authentication to active directory
the interesting part happens at at this
point once the user has been
authenticated
the ad connector calls the sts assume
roll method to
get temporary security credentials for
that user using those temporary security
credentials adconnector constructs a
sign-in url
that users use to access the console and
if a user's mapped to multiple roles the
user will be presented with a choice at
the sign in time
as to which role they want to assume
these are sessions valid for
an hour which is pretty standard for
cloud apps
since the 80 connector environment is
hosted in aws
this would need to be targeted in order
to potentially impersonate the users
and be able to leverage that that
sts assume role method
microsoft's pass-through authentication
is similar
because with pass microsoft pass through
authentication or pta
it provides users the ability to
authenticate to azure active directory
which is passed through to the on-prem
id and validate it with
validated in azure ad by getting the
status back from the pta
agent in the on-prem environment pta is
enabled via azure ad connect
the users use the same passwords
assigned into both on-prem and
cloud-based applications
the communication between an agent azure
id is secured using certificate-based
authentication
and these certificates are automatically
renewed every few months by azure ad
i couldn't figure out what happens if
you get one of these certificates but
that could be pretty interesting
but ultimately this supports user
sign-in into all web browser-based
applications and into off microsoft
office client applications that use
modern authentication
adam chester aka xpn has done a great
blog post
on how to leverage a compromised azure
ad connect server
with pta enabled in order to gather user
names and clear text passwords
that were used to authenticate via pta
so
since pass-through authentication is
managed by azure ad connect you can
compromise that server
and then during this authentication
process
azure ad sends the clear text password
dot hashed to authenticate the user
so it's sent to azure ad connect azure
ad connect
pta component is going to check and
validate the
username and password with active
directory then send back the status to
azure ad for that
so adam identified that you could inject
a dll to compromise the credentials that
were used for pta
and then have those credentials for
anyone that was using pta
azure active directory seamless single
sign-on or azure ad seamless sso
automatically signs users in when they
are on their corporate devices connected
to the corporate network
this graphic is interesting and nice but
i prefer this one because it has a lot
more of the flow
but basically what ends up happening is
that users don't need to type in their
passwords to sign into azure ad
or even really type in their usernames
it provides the users easy access to
their cloud-based applications without
any additional on-prime components like
federation
this is done by converting the on-prime
authentication to cloud authentication
through a computer account in
active directory so michael grafener
from
ds internals posted this article a few
years ago
or a couple years ago where he was
talking about how the
azure ad has a publicly available
endpoint that accepts these kerberos
tickets and translates them into saml
and jwt tokens
that can be leveraged for cloud apps
effectively if you can compromise the
azure ad seamless single sign-on
computer account
the password has associated with it the
computer account is is called azure ad
sso acc and can be identified it's in
the computer's container
if you're able to compromise this and
get this password hash you could
generate a silver ticket for
any for any user you want to impersonate
and the service
that you use in the silver ticket is
going to be aadg.windows.net.nsatc.net
you inject this ticket into the local
kerberos cache
and azure 80 seamless single sign-on the
computer account password doesn't
actually change
microsoft does recommend that it gets
rolled and changed at least every 30
days
what's interesting is because it's a
computer account
there is no actual computer that is
behind the scenes that that
is using that computer account other
than the azure ad connect client
so normally a computer in in active
directory would update the computer
account password that's associated with
that computer
since there isn't really a computer here
that password isn't getting changed
so maybe in the future microsoft will
code into azure ad connect to
automatically update
the computer account password for this
three years ago at defcon 25 in las
vegas i co-presented a talk called
hacking the cloud
i talked about how azure ad connects
password hash sync permissions
provided mimikat's dc sync writes and
that the author of mimikat's ec sync
vincent litto was inspired by password
hash sync to create dc sync because phs
requests password hashes
for sync users on a regular basis
we can scan active directory domain
permissions looking for potential
azure ad connect service counts or
if the azure ad connect install would
use the
express install option then there's a
helpful description on the account
noting on which server azure 80 connect
is installed
we can then check in active directory to
figure out where that computer is stored
very often this is in the servers oh you
or somewhere similar
once we know the server name and we can
check for
and and its location the actual
distinguished name of the ou that it's
in
we can check 80 for any group policies
that add 80 groups to the local
administrators group
compromising any account that is a
member of the local administrators group
on the azure ad connect server would
result in compromise of
the azure ad connect server and
ultimately active directory assuming
that it has
pass hash sync password hash
synchronization rights
configured in the environment also if we
can modify a group policy that links to
the azure ad connect server ou
then we can compromise the server that
way as well
when talking about cloud environments
it's important to mention how
administration is performed
this is commonly referred to as identity
access management or i
am so we've gone from groups in our
on-prem environment with active
directory to roles where the which is
effectively these rights that are
packaged together
azure in it aws and gcp have their own
methods but a lot of the concepts are
effectively the same azure im uses the
concept of an owner a contributor and a
reader
the owner has full access the
contributor has the ability to
create and manage the resources but
can't grant access to others
and then a reader can just view things
and so azure has the tenant which is the
top level
container of the azure environment and
this contains subscriptions
the tenant admins are effectively the
owner role on the tenant and
subscription admin would be effectively
the owner role
on the subscription
what's interesting is that microsoft
notes that azure roles and azure 80
roles are separate and different
mostly and i'll cover that in a little
bit
aws has a root account often called or
referred to as a payer account which is
the primary account
though it really shouldn't be used
regularly then there are account admins
so in aws the account is similar to the
azure tenant it's the top level
container for
the environment for that customer the
account admins have full control over
the account
if an account is a root account and an
admin account then that account has full
organizational control it's important to
note here that any overscoped roles
provide escalation capability
and rhino security labs has an extensive
article covering
21 aws ion privilege escalation methods
which allow an attacker to escalate from
a compromised low privilege account to
full admin privileges
so i've listed a bunch of them here i
apologize for the small text
but really what you want to do is you
want to read the blog
article that they wrote which is linked
at the bottom and in the slides
they also released the scanning tool
which is on github to identify these
vulnerabilities
in a aws user account
and if you have an account with imread
access for all users the script can be
run against every user in the account
to detect these vulnerabilities account
wide so if you're asked to pen test aws
or you're providing security consulting
services
around aws or even you're working an
organization you're moving to aws and
you have some of the imrols configured
you definitely want to scan them for
potential escalation methods
api keys i'm just going to cover this
really quickly
they provide permanent access to an
environment often with extensive
privileges
these keys can often bypass the typical
username and password used to
authenticate as an account
if it's configured as such
well i've covered a number of scenarios
on how to attack on-prem and hybrid
cloud components
let's focus on on-prem active directory
domain controllers
hosted in cloud infrastructure as a
service
so first up is amazon aws ec2
many organizations leverage amazon aws
ec2 or is as a cloud data center
some of these host on-prem ad domain
controllers
in aws so we start with acme corporation
which has the
on-prem ad environment they've stood up
an
amazon aws account to use ec2 as a cloud
data center then acme configures an im
role for the server admins and they
stand up a couple of
on-prem active directory domain
controllers in aws
acme then configures federation so that
users in the on-prem ad can authenticate
to aws
using their 80 credentials to simplify
access for server admins the on-prem 80
group aws
ec2 admins is created and then that's
associated with aws
iamroll the server team accounts are
then added to the on-prem awad
group called aws ec2 admins to enable
the team to easily administer
the aws environment
but if an attacker is able to compromise
one of the user accounts that's a member
of the 80 group aws
admins
then they are able to connect to the aws
console as an aws admin
and then now the attacker can configure
the virtual domain controller instance
in aws and run commands on it
once the command runs to modify the
domain controller's copy of ad
the changes replicate back to the
on-prem domain controllers
and then we end up with the on-prem
active directory being compromised
so effectively in the scenario the
attacker can compromise an account a
regular user account
that doesn't have any active directory
rights it's just a member of a group
in active directory this group is
associated with the aws
i am role through federation and so once
the attacker compromises this account
which has these rights
granted in the group in active directory
but then are relayed and related to this
aws i
am role then they can leverage that in
order to compromise
any of the systems that are in there
that they have rights to
so i've got a summary slide here that
covers this very
briefly but keep in mind that amazon ssm
which is effectively the amazon agent
is installed by default on most amazon
provided instances or templates
you do need the role to execute but once
you have the rights over that
environment as a server admin would you
can normally go ahead and get that
hopefully you're logging this and
looking at the logs amazon cloudtrail
can pull these logs
and the logs need to be configured to
not be deleted
so very often an attacker is just going
to delete the logs so you can't see what
they did
for most of 2019 i was digging in office
365 and azure active directory looking
at features
as i went through each of them i found
one that was very interesting
remember earlier how i noted that azure
roles and azure 80 roles are separate
well not exactly
here it describes a way that global
administrators could actually elevate
their access and have some control over
azure surely the global administrator
role description notes this right
well no it didn't at least not as of may
the global administrator role provides
full admin rights to azure ad and
ultimately all the office 365 services
the microsoft online demo document
provides key information about this
and there's nothing here showing azure
capability i took the screenshot in may
after contacting microsoft providing
information about this escalation path
the document's been updated in the past
past month or so stating that yes there
is a way for global administrator to
have
azure rights which is a bit different
than what it said before
once we have access to the azure ad
portal which is typically all azure 80
users by default we can view
several different configuration settings
for azure act directory which controls
many aspects of office 365.
this page shows the directory properties
which now includes the new managed
security defaults
towards the bottom is access management
for azure resources toggle
so we can see what that is according to
microsoft documentation toggling this
option from no to yes
adds the global administrator account to
the user access administrator role in
azure
are back at the root scope this has
control
over all subscriptions in the tenant and
this option is only available to
accounts that are members of the global
administrator role
while this option is configured in the
directory properties section this is
actually a per account configuration
option
so this magic button provides ability to
manage azure roles
but no direct azure rights as into vms
further in the document documentation
there's additional context on what
elevate access is and how it works when
developing azure active directory in
azure microsoft had to decide if the
global admin
should have azure rights initially and
opted for no they shouldn't
but they provided this capability to
gain azure access
this is that back door of sorts which
has been somewhat highlighted now that
the managed security default option is
right below it
so this graphic shows what happens in
the connection point between azure ad
and azure
my biggest concern here is that for many
organizations the group that manages
azure act directory and office 365 are
often a different group
from those that manage azure this means
that someone could elevate access
i think a rogue admin and no one
probably would notice
this potentially a serious threat from
an insider threat perspective
especially around the detection part of
this issue which i'll cover in a bit
this note in the microsoft document
highlights an interesting phenomena with
this option
only while the account is a member of
the global administrator role can the
account toggle this option to yes or no
this means that if an account is no
longer
in the global administrator role and the
option has been set to yes
they cannot change it back to no and no
one else can change it either
i also found an api that seems related
which means that an attacker would not
need to visit the azure id portal to
perform this action
they just have to run this api call
and ryan added this rest api elevation
method to powerjar which you should
check out
i have a link at the bottom of the slide
now what i'm going to do is walk through
a scenario where we have acme and
acme has uh stood up uh they
they've have a new office 365
environment they've had azure for a very
long time they've
using it azure as their cloud data
center they've got domain controllers
there they've got a bunch of different
servers in azure
but they're just now spinning up office
365 they're going to use it for email
they're going to use it for a number of
different things so
they have members of the active
directory team exchange sharepoint
a bunch of different prop people
probably 30 to fifty people
are members of the global administrator
role not everyone has had their account
configured for mfa
uh which is realistic since uh many
admins this is from last year's black
hat talk
that i gave with mark morrow and it was
only about eight percent um
hopefully it's much higher than that but
it's still probably less than fifteen
percent i if i had to guess
and so this means that most global admin
accounts don't have mfa configured and
so if an attacker is able to password
spray
and guess the account uh password then
they're able to take over this account
so by default this option is set to no
so if an attacker compromises a global
admin account
they can go in and actually toggle this
from node yes which gives them
azure user access administrator role
uh rights at the root of azure that
azure tenant
of uh that's configured uh within the on
the azure side
so once that toggle option is set to yes
we can see a new account appears in the
user
access administrator you azure rbac role
i call this attack account hacker so i
don't forget which one i'm using
but you'll notice that i also added a
couple others that look like they belong
there's really nothing that's supposed
to be in this role
monitoring for this can be a challenge
since the primary method is running an
azure cli command at the root scope
i can't find root level azure our back
roles listed in the portal so i can't go
there to see what the membership is
so some that could be monitored through
an api or if you're pulling logs
into your sim you could alert on rbac
roll or roll
membership modification but when i run
that command
i get this output which means i would
have to parse it
and so this is the message that appears
when attempting to remove root level of
role assignments from a subscription
removing an account from a root level
azure our back role requires running an
azure powershell command
when an account toggles elevate access
from yes to no it is automatically
removed from the user access
administrator
once the attacker has user access
administrator rights at the root level
this account can modify roles for any
subscription in azure
owner's obvious and probably monitored
maybe what about something more
innocuous
so i found virtual machine contributor
and this is pretty interesting because
the documentation states
it lets you manage virtual machines but
not access to them and not the virtual
network or storage
account that they're connected to and it
includes this ability which is
microsoft dot compute slash virtual
machine slash run command
this provides the ability to run
commands on the vm as system such as
powershell
and so we can click on run powershell
script and we can do that
the other thing that's interesting here
is that it provides the ability to
re-enable the administrator account
which on a domain controller in azure
would be the rid 500 account for the
domain
so we have seen some environments when
we look at them from an act directory
assessment perspective
they have had the default domain
administrator account disabled
but very often it has an old password uh
say 10 years old or more and it may
actually have a
kerberos service principal name or spin
associated with it which means that we
could curb roast it
so if an attacker could just go ahead
and kerberos it
then re-enable it through here they
could potentially leverage that
default admin account which was
originally disabled
so we're going to add the attacker
control account to the virtual machine
contributor
and now that our attacker has the
ability to run commands we can update
the administrators group
this will happen on the azure based
domain controller then replicate to the
domain controllers that are on-prem
note that being able to run commands on
an azure vm is not specific to customer
on-prem dc's hosted on azure
but also other systems hosted there as
well
so we take a look to see what happened
we can go switch to a computer on-prem
or run another command
on the dc to see what the result is and
we've now compromised the on-prem active
directory from
azure if powershell logging is
configured appropriately and sent to a
sim and monitored
this event should identify unusual
activity showing up in the powershell
log
another option an attacker has with
these rights is running invoke mimikats
from the internet or even a compromise
system on the corporate network
or within the azure tenant so here i'm
running mini cats just to get the curb
cd password hash
because with that i can create golden
tickets which means i can persist
forever
in the on-prem active directory even
though i've never touched that
or had access to the corporate network
so that means once i get a foothold i
can have domain admin
possibly forever but what if instead of
running invoke mimicas directly from
github we loaded it into azure blob
storage so effectively we're going to
use a powershell script we're going to
upload
i'm not going to call it invokementcat
so i'll call it invmmk.txt
and azure blob storage is very nice
because it gives me a url
from which in which i can interact and
connect to this
this file so that would work as well
let's take a moment to recap from global
admin to
azure user access administrator to azure
admin or virtual machine
contributor so if an attacker
compromises an organization's global
administrator account either because
they are just starting with office 365
or didn't realize the risks around
protecting global admins
either way the global admin accounts
weren't locked down with pim conditional
access or mfa
or a global admin session token was
stolen because this admin
was using their regular web browser on
the regular user workstation
which was compromised this would mean
that the attacker is about an hour to
perform these actions
compromise the account elevate access to
azure get access to get azure rights
through
azure roll membership remove elevate
access rights perform malicious act
actions on any or all azure vms and all
subscriptions
then remove role membership in azure or
not the total time required only a few
minutes perhaps as much as 15 minutes
total
in many organizations there are two
different groups that manage azure ad
office 365
and azure as i mentioned earlier they
have no expectations
that the other team has the ability to
affect their environment
so why is this issue as important well
customers don't usually expect that the
global administrator role
that says it has office 365 admin rights
can also control azure subscriptions
we need to be very careful what accounts
are members of roles in azure at the
root level
as well as on the subscriptions since
this impacts the security posture
it's not obvious that removing the
account from global administrator role
does not remove the account from the
azure our rbac role
user access administrator when the
access management for azure resources
toggle option is still set to yes
and the key points around detection is
there's no way to detect this
configuration azure active directory at
all
there's no property to query on accounts
you have to run an azure cli command to
check the role group membership but
that's in the on the azure side
when i walked through the azure ad to
azure access elevation
i attempted to identify a clear event
that i could alert on and was unable to
the core directory directory management
set company information log notes that
something has changed but not what
the capability for an azure ad global
admin is quote unquote by design
however not expected not well documented
by microsoft when reading about
what azure 80 global admins can do
certainly now the documentation has been
updated
to to mention this but i feel like there
should be better
logging and alerting around this sort of
configuration
i'm concerned that in this is a scenario
where the microsoft cloud customer
can't detect can't remediate and
ultimately can't prevent
since there's no real gate to lock if an
azure ad global admin account is exposed
and then they can jump over on the azure
side so the only real good answer i can
find for this is to ensure that
global administrator groups are managed
or the roles are managed with azure
adpim
but even this doesn't stop a rogue admin
from doing whatever they want
the best mitigation is to prevent
compromise of global admin accounts
using pim reduces this risk tremendously
outside of that monitor global admin
role membership in azure ad and the user
access administrator group at the azure
root level
regarding sensitive systems severely
restrict who has access to them placing
them in a separate subscription
will protect against common over
permissioning but not against this sort
of attack
so leveraging a separate azure 10 is the
best method for isolating and securing
sensitive systems
including domain controllers i reported
this
issue to microsoft security in september
of 2019 continued corresponding with
them providing additional details
through the rest of the year again my
biggest concern with this is that on the
azure 80 side there is no way to detect
remediate or prevent a global admin from
flipping the switch and gaining full
azure rights
instead of an external attacker what if
there was a malicious insider someone
who did not benefit from the company's
spared no expense mantra and we know
what happened in that scenario
but how bad could it really get let's
play what if
what if an attacker takes control of
azure resources
what if the attacker then removes all
the accounts from all the roles
and what if they decide to ransom the
azure environment azure ransomware
azure where yeah that could be pretty
bad
so let's take the cloud architecture
concepts to the next level pretty much
where
organizations are headed let's say you
start with the typical microsoft server
architecture with on-prem active
directory
and then we're going to add azure to it
and then we're going to add aws to the
mix
and then we're going to add google cloud
platform and so
i'm just going to provide a simplified
view of this because really the
architecture diagrams get pretty messy
we have aws we have azure and we have
google cloud platform
and i simplify this like i said showing
the on-prem data center
and federation to the three different
cloud environments but ultimately
this federation just means that we have
this sort of configuration where
everything can talk to everything else
and that they're interconnected and this
means a compromise in one will likely
lead to a compromise in all cloud
environments since the im story is quite
different in each and difficult to track
roles and privileges across them
it's likely the accounts are over
permission in the scenario and
the use of federation provides the
ability to jump across
between these different environments so
compromise of all three cloud
environments will likely result in
on-prem compromise since there's likely
on-prem
80 domain controllers in one or more of
the cloud environments federation or any
type of authentication flow really
between these environments enables a new
type of lateral movement
the attacker could leverage over
privileged azure and aws roles and the
rights provided with them
and showing which ones can provide
system access to vms
despite how they're described is one way
that we can identify
and lock down those those controls or
those roles
but the attacker could jump across the
federation to gain privileged access to
cloud-hosted services and systems once
they compromise a single system
or even an account because ultimately
gaining privileged access to the is
service provider
so azure amazon aws gcp means that the
attacker could do anything with the vms
hosted in the environment including
accessing and modifying data on the
systems
so it's very important that
administrative roles need to be limited
and gated i recently heard a customer
tell me that an executive was concerned
about putting all their eggs in one
basket
so they signed up for azure and aws and
google cloud platform
so now their eggs are in all the baskets
and the security capabilities and
controls across these environments is
quite different
and it's up to the operation and
security teams to figure that part out
so
the cloud provides many benefits and
power though cloud integration often
complicates security
organizations will have to do better to
map security between on-prem and cloud
systems and authentication
it's important as a security
professional or security hobbyist to
learn about these things so cloud is the
wild west
at this point is the whole brave new
world if you want to go far in your
career focus on cloud and cloud security
because it is wide open
there's a lot of areas that haven't been
explored and especially
in those areas across uh hype
on-prem and the hybrid environment so
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done there
and there's a lot that we need to do
moving forward to
improve the security in this environment
that's been my time
thank you very much for yours